Heat. Heat. N.
[Music]
Heat. Hey, hey,
hey. Heat. Heat. N.
[Music]
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
[Music]
Heat.
Heat. Heat. Heat.
[Music]
N. Heat. Heat.
[Applause]
[Music]
Hey. Hey. Hey.
candy truth.
[Music]
going to talk about the truth and we're
going to get canon with it. The star is
born Eli truth in the White House. A new
world order
prophecy. Is not an alien force already
among us?
We're going to talk about the
truth and we're going to get candid with
it. Candid
truth. What is up everybody? Thank you
for joining us at Candid Truth. We're
going to talk about the truth and we're
going to get candid with it. This world
just keeps getting sicker and sicker.
Bible prophecy is coming more true than
ever before. If you are an atheist or an
agnostic or just seeking or questioning,
open up the Bible. Turn to Revelation.
and you will see that we are living in
it. Now, you know, there was a time when
Satan actually tried to hide, you know,
sugarcoat things and uh you had to
really dig deep and try to find the
secrets that were hidden in movies and
TV shows and things like that back in
the days of I Love Lucy. They used to
sleep in separate beds and it seemed
like, you know, there was actually some
morals and stuff in the media. But, uh,
as of the past few recent years, all
that's gone out the window. Now, what
they call good is evil and evil is good.
Right? That's the days that we're living
in. That bitter is sweet, sweet is
bitter. Satan doesn't even try to hide.
We have shows like Lucifer and an anime
called The Seven Deadly Sins who are
against the Ten Commandments. I mean, it
can be that clear. And yet, the world is
still blind, still sleeping, and we're
trying to awaken the sleeping giant.
Look, the days are evil. That's what the
Bible says that we're coming to a time
when the days are evil and there's no
hiding it anymore. So, we talk about
this stuff to try and wake you up. And
whether you're a non-believer, we're
going to show you that the Bible is
true, that the days are getting more
wicked and wicked and wicked, and people
just think, "No, we're just getting
freer and we're getting more
experimental or I don't know what kind
of terminology you would use to justify
the things that are happening these days
where if you don't cut your child's
genitals off, we'll take them away by
law." or if you don't address a a boy as
a girl or as a cat or all these things
like we are living in bizarro world and
if you can't see that then you are you
have been blinded by the god of this
world that's what the Bible says that
Satan is the god of this world and he's
blinding the minds of the people that
are here and we are clearly living in
that time period I want to show you a
commercial that KFC put out this is a
KFC official commercial and it's very
disturbing I mean, there there's a lot
of weird commercials lately. I mean,
Skittles and all this stuff, they've
been pushing the boundaries of being
weird. I get it. Weird. Okay, maybe
there's nothing too wrong with being
strange, but a lot of these products,
they don't even they don't even look
like they're selling the product
anymore. Uh, you know, these Old Spice
commercials and stuff, you just have
something completely random and twisted
and strange and weird and then it's
like Old Spice or
It has nothing to do with the product
and then they just slap a product label
on there. Well, here's another
commercial kind of like that. But it's
not just weird. It's literally occultic,
satanic, cannibalistic, and disgusting
on every level. And we're going to check
that out right now. If you guys have not
seen this, uh, you're in for something
weird. I'm not going to turn the volume
up. It's really just some strange music.
Anyway, but we're going to address this.
So, this guy's walking in the woods.
Notice what he's wearing. He's wearing
his own clothes. And there's a chicken.
He's noticing this chicken that's
intriguing him. And he looks up and the
jacket comes down on this girl. And
notice what she's wearing. All
brown. So, she's wearing all brown. She
approaches him. He's kind of mystified
by her. And then all these people come
out of the woodwork. Literally out of
the woodwork in the woods. They're all
wearing brown. Notice like some cult or
some monks or something and they all
gather around and they raise them up and
now notice what he's wearing. He's
wearing what they're wearing. He's
joined the cult. I'm not making this
stuff up. I'm not just saying, "Oh, it
looks like a cult." They will tell you
it's a cult. And here they are. They're
dancing around this golden egg. We're
actually going to be covering what the
golden egg is. There's an occult meaning
behind the golden egg and just in
general the egg. Um there's all
these sightings and uh whistleblowers
saying that an alien craft was found and
it's the shape of an egg. Why is it an
egg? Why are we Why are we coming into
this new age, the golden age that
Trump's talking about? Why are there
these eggs? It's all symbolic. There's
all a reason behind it. But now notice
the guy who just joined the cult.
They're all raising the egg, which is
literally signifying the new golden age
of the age of Aquarius, where we're
entering into
this shift in humanity. And this girl
picks him up, takes him into the water,
which is actually boiling grease, and uh
she baptizes him. She's baptizing him in
the boiling
grease and raises him up as
a roast a a fried piece of chicken and
it says believe in chicken. That's what
I'm saying. I'm not just saying, "Oh,
this is kind of culty." They're telling
you this is about believe. Believe in
chicken. Now, if you think, "Oh, this is
maybe this isn't even really connected
to KFC." No. The link on the page takes
you to
kFC.co.uk. This is in the UK. And notice
it's right there on their site. All hail
gravy. Hail. What does that even mean?
Let's look it up. I just just for the
fun of it. Define hail. You know, it
might say like frozen rain. Yep. Or
uh what does it mean to hail something?
Define hail something.
to cheer, salute, to greet, to welcome,
to acclaim, approve, enthusiastic. I
thought it would say something more like
worship. Considering when Hitler had his
army, they would say, "Hi, Hitler." And
uh in the Catholicism, they say, "Hail
Mary," right? All hail gravy. They're
not hiding the religious aspect of this.
Actually, when you look at their
official YouTube channel, first I want
to show you the comments. Check out the
comments. So, there's
99.7,000 subscribers to this KFC KFC
UKI. And notice what the the subject
line says. By the way, in 9 days, this
video got 164,000 views. And in the the
description of the video, it says, "Do
you find yourself lost in the woods of
modern life? Fear not, for salvation in
sauce is near." This is blasphemous.
trust in the thumping sound of the
golden egg. So, now we're talking about
those tribal drums. If you didn't see
that, we covered uh Lady Gaga on SNL
when it was a blatant satanic ritual
abuse. And they're making a a joke out
of it, ripping the heart out of the
girl. They put her in a cage, ripped her
heart out, and served her heart to her
friends as a bloody Sunday. And and they
were like, "Oh, you hear the tribal
thumping?" This is what they're talking
about again. Trust the thumping sound of
the golden egg. Trust in the liquid gold
elixir. And it says, "Trust in the
divine dunk." The divine dunk. This is
blasphemy. If there's anything divine
about a dunk, it's about being baptized
into Christ, into newness of life, into
uh salvation, which they already said
salvation is in the
sauce. Trust in the divine dunk. and
whisper the sacred words, "All hail
gravy." Because there's some things we
can still believe in. Believe in
chicken. So why why the connection to
religion? Why does it always got to come
back to religion? Even the SNL thing,
why they have to do a skit about a
satanic ritual where they rip a girl's
heart out and all that? There's nothing
funny about it. And yet everything has
to come back to religion. even the KFC
commercial. So, I want you to see the
comments because the comments actually
give me hope for humanity. Um, mocking
baptism and saying they use human meat
if anyone wishes to know. Never eating
KFC again. Why does a KFC advertisement
need cultism and cannibalism?
Interesting, isn't it? WTF? The people
who thought this up need help. KFC sells
1.6 million pieces of chicken every
week. There is not enough chicken to
maintain their stock for a whole year.
They are telling you they've been using
human meat. Sick. 106 people like that.
Thanks, KFC. Now I know your chicken is
actually human meat. I will no longer be
eating KFC. Creepy and demonic. So now
we have a golden calf replaced by an
alien egg-shaped idol and some demonic
carvings on it. Then a mockery of
baptism, ba, human sacrifice, and fire
in the lake of boiling oil. And finally,
unholy communion to be still received by
by deceived masses. Best places to hide.
Best place to hide a secret is in plain
sight. These comments are getting 97
thumbs up. I'm telling you, this is so
in your face that nobody can deny it.
100% of the comments that I've read have
been against what is going on. And when
you see out
of
164,000 views, it has 748 thumbs up. You
do the math. What percent is that? like
1% will will be gracious and say 1%. 748
thumbs up out
of 146,000 views is not even 1%. Why
would a company purposely make a
commercial so blasphemous, so demonic,
so cannibalistic that it would hurt
their business? Why? Because maybe these
corporations are being offered
something. Maybe they're getting some
kind of kickback from the one that
they've made a deal with. And and maybe
whoever is offering that deal says,
"Hey, if you make this commercial that
will desensitize the youth of this
country, this world, then we will make
sure you're well taken care of." I don't
know. You know, I'm just I'm trying to
grasp at anything at this point because
why in the world would you make a
commercial like this when you know it's
going to hurt your business? Fox News
recently said that KFC releasing apparel
collection with items selling for nearly
$400. And here's some of the apparel. I
don't know why anybody would want to
wear a shirt that says Kentucky Fried
Chicken, but it says humanmade original
recipe. That just doesn't even make as
as just like sentence structure English.
I don't know. Humanmade original recipe.
Who else would make the recipe? Um, I
don't know. But there is a lot of
controversy about meat industries not
even using real meat. Uh, using things
that are synthetic or even human meat.
And when you do things like have
products that say human-made recipes or
dunking a human in a vat of grease and
lifting them up as a fried piece of
chicken. It's almost like they're
telling you, right? And why do they
wonder and people wonder why we ask
these types of questions, you know, when
they're putting this stuff so in your
face? Because when you put something
boldly in your face, it it desensitizes
you. It makes you think, "Ah, there's no
way. Why would they openly tell you?"
Because a lot of times that's reverse
psychology. If we put it in your face,
then then you won't believe it. It's
just like uh you know these things like
at at Denver airport where there was
literally like the the mural that was
showing the whole new world order thing
and and people were saying no I'm
hearing sounds in the basement. They're
they're building tunnels and bunkers and
so they started putting up these walls
these fake walls to hide the
construction site with an alien. And it
would say yes we're down here making the
the deep bunkers and they'd say stuff
like oh this is where the secret society
meets. They're putting the truth in your
face so that you won't believe it. It's
reverse psychology. Now, you say, "Well,
wait a minute. They can't be true
because they're putting it right out
there. They're making a joke about it.
So, I must have been overreacting or
whatever." Um, but this is the signs of
the times. I want to read some
scriptures about the times that we're
living in. Second Timothy chapter 3
says, "This know also that in the last
days perilous times shall come." We are
in a time of perilous times. I mean, so
many people are sick and dying, and
there's earthquakes and floods, and
people aren't being helped the way they
should be. For men shall be lovers of
their their own selves, covetous,
boasters, proud. What does it say?
Blasphemers. Blasphemers. Just like
Saturday Night Live, just like KFC is
doing, disobedient to parents,
unthankful, unholy, just like songs like
Sam Smith or unholy and all this stuff.
They're putting it in your faces more
and more every day. Without natural
affection, truce breakers, false
accusers, incontinent, fierce, despisers
of those who are good. I see that every
day. The world hates you. If you reflect
the character of Christ, if you call sin
what it is, if you say that lifestyle is
wrong or that action is wrong, then they
hate you for
it. Despisers of those who are good.
Just even if you don't even point the
sin out, you just live a good righteous
life. Oh, you know, I'm I believe in
having a nuclear family and being a part
of a heterosexual family with the
children and wife stays home and takes
care of the house and I go to work. Oh,
you
misogynistic patriarchal pig. You know,
it's like they despise you just for
living righteously the way that God
created this whole world to work.
traitors, heady, high-minded, lovers of
pleasure more than lovers of God. That
even happens in the Christian world.
More people are are concerned about
doing what feels good to them than what
God has for their life. Something that
he's the creator. He knows the best for
us. And yet, we will reject his ways
just to do what we like, what feels good
to us. having a form of godliness but
denying the power thereof from such turn
away. So we have that too. We I mean
there's people these celebrities even
will say yeah I'm I'm a Christian. I
believe in God and turn around and be
doing terrible things doing movies with
adultery or satanic rituals or whatever
and say no I believe in God. Lady Gaga
pretends to pray before shows and she
pretends to believe in God and she's a
Catholic and all these things. This is
what it's talking about having a form of
godliness but denying the power thereof.
They're getting their power from some
other source. Isaiah 5:20 says, "Woe
unto them that call evil good and good
evil, that put darkness for light and
light for darkness, that put bitter for
sweet and sweet for bitter." This is the
days we're living in. They do not want
to hear good. They only want to see
evil. And evil can be right in front of
your face now. And if you call it for
what it is, you're just some religious
zealot. You You just You don't get it.
You're not You're no fun. You're a stick
in the mud, whatever. But really, we
just have eyes to see. Eyes to see and
ears to hear are our gifts of God. And
so spiritual things are spiritually
discerned. And Satan has blinded the
minds of this world. Revelation 22:11
says, "He that is unjust, let him be
unjust still. And he which is filthy,
let him be filthy still. He that is
righteous, let him be righteous still.
And he that is holy, let him be holy
still." See, Christ is coming soon. I
believe that with all my heart. He is
coming soon. And right now, there is a
line being drawn in the sand. You must
choose ye this day whom you will serve.
You're either going to choose God or
you're going to choose the enemy. And if
you're choosing the pleasures of this
world, then you are rejecting Christ. It
is time to wake up. Let him who is just
be just still. Let him who is unjust be
unjust still. There's coming a time
where the ark, the door of the ark is
closing. And if you're on the outside,
you cannot knock on that door and get in
anymore. The rain is coming and the door
is sealed. Choose ye this day whom you
will serve. Let's choose today to live
for Christ every day, picking up our
cross daily, helping others who are in
need, praying for others, expanding
God's kingdom because time is running
short. I hope this was eye- openening to
you. I hope this made it clear that we
are living in the last days because it's
not just this commercial, guys. Just
look at the majority of what's on
television. What's the mainstream media
is just pumping out this sewage slime.
Turn this junk off. Open the pages of
the Bible. Let's get in God's word
because that's the only thing that's
going to save us. If you enjoyed this
video, please give it a thumbs up.
Please share it with family and friends.
If you want to support this ministry,
you can do so by going to
candidtruth.org. We got some digital
ways to give. If you like t-shirts, we
got some cool t-shirts on the website
that really helps this ministry to
continue doing what we're doing because
we cannot do this without you. We love
you guys and we thank you and we'll see
you next time on Candid Truth.